Um okay, so today we're going to
continue with uh
Bayes-Nash equilibrium. Last class was a
bit of a theoretical class where we
defined the concept and we went over the
foundations.
Today we're actually going to solve some
examples.
So we're going to solve an example of
Cournot competition.
And then we're going to get started with
auctions, which is one of my favorite
topics and we'll cover that uh for a few
lectures.
>> [clears throat]
>> So let's start with an example of
Cournot competition
with unknown demand.
So you recall that the the model of
Cournot competition we've introduced so
far, it was assumed that both firms
exactly knew the demand curve. They
exactly knew uh what the price would be
as a function of both of the quantities
that was set. But that's kind of an
unrealistic assumption. So let's now
suppose that the demand
or
more precisely the inverse demand
P of Q
before we just said it was 1 minus Q.
Let me write what we had before and then
I'll change it.
Before we wrote something like this.
So that if the quantity Q was produced
on the market
then the price was either 1 minus Q
unless Q was really really high, in
which case the price was zero.
But what we're going to look at today is
what if this intercept that used to be a
one is now a theta.
And theta is unknown.
Or theta is
going to be private information.
>> [clears throat]
>> So we're going to look at I guess the
simplest possible case where one of the
firms knows the value of theta but the
other firm does not.
So let's assume that
let's say theta
can take two possible values and let's
assume they're each uh they each occur
with probability 1/2. So kind of the
easiest case. So theta
is an element of
well, either theta low or theta high.
And each with probability 1/2.
Um
Great. So
of course we're going to assume here
that the labels make sense. So theta L
is
smaller than theta H.
So if theta if the state is theta H
this is a
high demand state and it means that for
a given level of quantity that we put in
the market, the market price is going to
be higher because it turns out that more
people like the good than we necessarily
expected.
If the demand state is theta L, then
that's the lower number here and for a
given quantity Q that's produced, the
price is going to be lower because
there's going to be less demand for the
product. So this is certainly relevant
when a firm is introducing a new
product. They don't know how popular
it's going to be. They may have some
uncertainty about that and that's what
this is capturing here.
Okay? And we're going to assume that
firm one
observes theta
but firm two does not.
So one story could be that firm one is
kind of an experienced incumbent. They
know how fashions change and they're
able to predict what demand is going to
be. Firm two might be this new entrant
who doesn't have as much data, doesn't
have as much experience and they don't
know what theta is. Now of course, what
is assumed is that this distribution is
common knowledge.
So firm two knows or believes that the
state is equal to theta L with
probability 1/2 and theta H with
probability 1/2. They know that but they
don't know exactly which value it is.
And moreover, everything I've written on
the board is common knowledge, right?
This is this subtle thing. So firm two
knows that firm one knows the state.
And we're going to uh now write this
down for
So now let's try to solve for
And I guess the last component I need to
say, maybe I'll just say it here is
let's assume costs are zero just to make
it the the algebra a bit easier. So
uh marginal costs
equal zero.
So as usual with our Cournot
specification, your profit is your
quantity times your profit per unit,
which is price minus cost. In this case
cost is zero, so your payoff is just
your quantity times the market price.
Okay, so now I think the first step, so
now our goal
is solving for BNE.
Bayes-Nash equilibrium. I think
sometimes the hardest part, often the
hardest part of this exercise is
figuring out what a strategy is. So the
first step is to figure out what a
strategy is and once we've done that, I
think we're in pretty good shape, right?
So remember a strategy is going to need
to specify an action a player is going
to take
as a function of whatever their mental
state is. If they have two distinct
mental states, they can take different
actions in those states. So
uh
Any ideas here? Let's look at firm one
and firm two.
What are the strategies going to be for
each of these players? So not what the
equilibrium is, but just what kind of
object is it going to be? Yeah? The
strategy will be some non-negative
uh real numbers. So a quantity, right?
And that'll be a strategy for whom? For
both of them. Both have
the strategy. So close. So not quite. So
I think that's right for firm two.
So firm two is going to be choosing a
non-negative real number.
You're right, we have to be careful
here. So you're right, firm one will
wake up. They'll see that demand is
either high or low and they will
actually choose either they'll choose a
non-negative real number. But their
strategy has to be a complete contingent
plan. Yeah, you want to follow up on
that? Yeah. There should be two numbers.
Exactly. There should be two values for
the firm one based on theta low and one
for the one for theta low, one for
Great. So I'm glad you answered that
way. Your your first answer was a really
common thing that we see in exams and
all, so it's good that this came up. Um
it's tricky because firm one will
actually in reality choose a single
number, but their strategy has to
specify two numbers because it must be a
complete contingent plan. And if it
didn't specify two numbers, there's no
way for firm two could figure out what
to do because firm two doesn't know the
state of the world. So if they don't
know or don't form beliefs about how
firm one is behaving at each state of
the world, they're going to be in
trouble, right? So for firm two, it is
just a number. Maybe we'll call it Q2.
Maybe I'll
just say it's a non-negative number
here. But firm one can in principle
produce a different amount in in
situations or in states when demand is
high and in states when demand is low.
So they're going to choose two numbers
Q1
of theta L
and Q1 of
theta H and these are both going to be
non-negative quantity numbers, right?
If we want to think of this in terms of
our formalism from last week firm two
has a single type. They have a single
mental state. Sometimes we call that
like T bar.
And when I just write Q2, that's really
Q2 of T bar. It's the quantity they
produce for their single uh mental
state.
Firm one actually has two mental states
and if we the way we wrote it last time
is we would have written it something
like this. We would have said firm one
has type TL
and when their type is TL, they know the
state is theta L.
And when their type is TH, they know the
state is theta H. And if you wanted to
be really formal, we would write Q1 of
TL and Q1 of TH. But then you just have
to keep track of the Ts and the thetas
and we're going to sort of um take a
shortcut and write it this way, but the
understanding is that the reason we
write theta L here is this is the type
of firm one who knows for certain that
the state is theta L.
I want to be clear about that
interpretation.
Okay.
Um
So let me
put these in parentheses. Okay, so now
we want to solve for BNE, but I think
first it's kind of good to always try to
guess and form intuition about what our
answer is going to be.
So in equilibrium, how do you think Q1
of theta L Q1 of theta H and Q2 are
going to be ordered? Any any guesses
about how those three numbers might be
ordered? See if we can
form
some intuition in advance.
So think Imagine you're a firm. If you
think
uh this product is very very popular and
the market price is going to be very
very high, are you going to produce more
of the product or less of the product?
More of the product, right? So let's
start up here.
Between Q1 theta L and Q1 theta H, which
one do you think is going to be higher?
We think this is going to be higher,
right? And it will be. Now maybe a
trickier question, how do these two
compare to Q2? That's maybe
uh a bit harder. Somewhere in the
middle. Somewhere in the middle. Yeah,
exactly. So uh it turns out and this is
maybe not obvious and depends a bit more
on the details of the problem, but if
I'm firm two, I know there's a half
chance the state is theta L and a half
chance this is the state is theta H. So
it's sort of intuitive that the amount
I'm going to produce is somewhere in
between. Now it's a bit trickier because
when the state is theta L, it's also
going to change what firm one produces.
So I don't that's that conclusion is a
little sensitive to the specification,
but in this case that's going to be
true.
Okay, so let's try to write it down.
So we've gone through step one, which is
identifying the kinds of objects that
we're choosing, right? How many numbers
we have to choose, how many functions we
have to choose. The next step is to
write down the equilibrium conditions,
right? And the crucial thing about BNE,
Bayes-Nash equilibrium, is that we're
going to have a condition, an optimality
condition, for every type of every
player.
So remember
BNE, Bayes-Nash equilibrium
requires
optimality
for every type of every player.
And that means we're going to have a
different equation, a different
optimality condition for every type of
every player that says that type is
behaving optimally.
So in this problem, how many conditions
are we going to have?
Three, right? Because there's one type
of player two, so we're going to have
one condition for player two that says
player two is behaving optimally. And
then we're going to have two different
conditions for for firm one saying if
firm one is the high type and they
observe that demand is high, then
they're behaving optimally. And if they
observe that demand is low, then they're
also behaving optimally.
Now to write out these conditions, it's
nice to have a little math notation, so
I want to people may have seen this, but
I want to introduce it to make sure
we're on the same page. So um we often
write things like max, let's just go
through a simple example to define this
notation.
We might want to maximize some function
f over x and let's put some range in
here. Let's say x is between -1 and 1.
So what this expression denotes is the
maximum value of this function over this
range.
There's a different expression, a
different notation that we want,
which is the argmax.
Excuse this of f of x,
which is the set of x values, the set of
inputs that achieve this maximum. And
the easiest way to see it is just to go
through an example. So let's say f of x
is
uh x squared.
I think just doing a numerical example
is the easiest thing.
So maybe I'll just erase the f of x to
avoid confusion. Let's just
not have too many equal signs.
So what is the maximum value of x
squared over the domain where x ranges
from -1 to 1? This is just one, right?
So this is not not testing you the math,
but just the notation. This is the
number one because that's the highest
value that this actually Let me use two
to avoid confusion, sorry.
Uh cuz otherwise that would not be a
good choice. Okay. So the answer is two.
Uh what about here? The argmax of 2x
squared? Where is this maximum value of
two achieved? At what x points?
One and minus one, right? So when you
write argmax, this is actually a set
consisting of the two numbers one and
minus one.
So it's good to distinguish this max
says we take in a function, we take in a
domain, and it gives us the highest
value that that function takes over the
domain.
When you write argmax, when now what
we're returning is not the value, but an
input to the function, an argument of
the function, and we're saying which
arguments at which arguments in the
domain does the function achieve this
maximum?
So this is helpful notation because
often we'll write things like
x star is an element of the argmax.
And what this means is if you're if you
were someone who were choosing x and you
wanted to maximize this function, you
could choose either negative one or one
and those would both maximize the
function. And the way we would write
down that condition is to say x star,
the thing that you choose, is an element
of the argmax. It's an element of the
set of things that maximize the
function. So we'll use that notation
when we write down our equilibrium
conditions below. Any questions on this?
Basically the advantage of this is we
only have to write the function once. If
we had to say f of x is greater than
equal to f of x prime for all x prime,
you just have to write things twice and
when the formulas get long, this is a
nice nice way of writing.
Okay.
So now
after that digression, uh let's now
write out our optimality conditions for
this game. And as we said, there's going
to be three conditions. So we're going
to have the condition for maybe I'll say
f1, this is firm one,
when they know the state is low.
There's f1 beta h,
firm one when they know the state is
high,
and then there's f2, firm two, and they
don't know anything, there's only one
type of them, so we just need a single
optimality condition for the firm.
Okay?
And
uh we're looking for an equilibrium, so
we're looking for values of this that
form an equilibrium, so we'll probably
put stars in here. So what we're going
to get is this system of equations is
going to depend on maybe I'll call q1
star of beta l, q1 star of beta h, and
q2 star. Those are the three things
we're trying to solve for.
Um so let's start with
beta l. So what is
firm one choosing? They're choosing a
non-negative quantity. So what they're
choosing is q1 star
of beta l.
And we want this to be in the argmax of
something because we want this to be an
optimal choice for this firm when they
know that demand is low.
So we're going to say this is in the
argmax
over
q1 prime.
So what I'm saying here is I'm
what I want to fill in here is what is
the payoff to firm one if they know the
state is beta l,
they choose quantity q1 prime, and they
believe that the other firm is following
their equilibrium strategy.
So here we're going to have the expected
revenue or profit of firm one.
And to say that q1 star of beta l is in
the argmax is to say this level of
production maximizes the revenue of firm
one.
So what is it going to be? Well, if I
produce q1 prime, then my quantity is q1
prime,
but then I have to multiply that by my
revenue
uh
See, let me just write it like this. By
my revenue per unit.
So that means I need to plug in the
market price.
And we know that the market price is
going to be beta minus q. Okay?
So if I'm firm one, I know the state is
beta l. So I'm going to put in beta l
here.
And then I need to subtract
the amount that I produce,
minus q1 prime.
What else do I have to subtract?
Yeah?
Say it again? q2 star q2 star, exactly.
And this is it. So let's understand.
Because I'm know the state is beta l, I
use beta l when I'm computing what the
market price is going to be.
If I'm firm one and I choose quantity q1
prime
and I believe that my opponent is
following their equilibrium strategy of
producing q2 star, then this is going to
be the market price. And I'm going to
make that for every unit I produce,
which is q1 prime, and that's going to
give me revenue. Okay?
Now we're going to get a similar formula
for
uh beta h.
And I want to make it clear here, sorry,
q1 prime is a number here. So this might
look like a function being evaluated
somewhere, that's not what I mean, it's
just a number times another number. And
the primes don't mean derivatives,
they're just notation.
Uh
Okay.
So here it's exactly the same, but now
the market demand is different.
So the key difference here is even if we
both produce the same amount, the market
price that we face is going to be
different in the high state than it
would have been in the low state.
Okay? And now firm two, this is a bit of
a harder one.
So they're going to say the quantity I'm
actually producing is optimal among all
the quantities I could produce,
um but now they're in a bit of a tricky
situation because they don't know
what the state is.
So firm two needs to take expectations
over the state of the world.
So there's a half probability
that the state is high.
And if the state is high and firm two
chooses quantity q2 prime, let's write
that in here.
The question is what is the market price
going to be in the case that the state
is
high
in this equilibrium?
Well now we have I guess two the market
the state matters in two ways.
Because it's going to affect the actual
intercept in the
uh market price or the inverse demand
curve, but it's also going to affect
what firm one chooses because firm one's
choice is contingent on the state. So if
the state is high, we're going to get
beta h minus q2 prime minus q1 star
of beta h.
So you'll see actually here
a tricky thing for firm two is these
effects are actually going to go in
opposite directions. So if firm if um
if firm two if if it turns out the state
is high, that's good for firm one
because demand is going to be higher,
but it means their opponent is actually
going to produce more. And that kind of
uh
creates a bit of a those go in counter
failing directions. Uh and then we'll do
the other thing, what if what if the
state is low? Well, we're going to have
to change this and change this, right?
So we have
>> [snorts]
>> Notice the crucial point here,
it's the same q2 prime here
as here.
Of course, if I were firm two, I would
love to choose a different quantity when
the state is high than when the state is
low, but I'm unable to do that because
I'm not able to observe the state. So I
choose a single quantity q2 prime and I
take expectations over the state.
Okay, so here's our conditions. Um
let's just we won't fully solve it out
cuz it's just it gets a bit messy, but
let's just
reduce each of these to a first order
condition. So here we've stated it as an
argmax property, let's just write the
corresponding um
kind of equalities. Well, in this top
row, we can use our kind of trick. So,
let's maybe I'll just go through these
one more time.
In the top row, we're going to see that
Q1 prime should be half of theta L minus
Q2 star.
two
F1 theta H
We can immediately see that our initial
intuitive guess was correct in that Q1
star of theta H is higher than Q1 star
of theta L.
Because Q2 star is the same in these two
expressions, the only difference is
theta L is here and theta H is here and
we know theta H is higher than theta L.
Now, the harder one.
Let's say F2.
Uh
What's the trick here?
Uh it turns out we can distribute a
little bit.
Uh
So, I guess one kind of nice observation
to keep in mind is the half is important
to get the right value, but it's not
going to affect the maximizer, right?
Just like up here, if I maximize 3x
squared instead of 2x squared, the set
of maximizers would have been the same,
though the maximum value would have
changed. So, I don't actually have to
really worry about the half and then I
can factor the
Q2 prime
and I think we will get
Q2 star
equals it's going to be an average. So,
it's going to be
maybe
theta L
plus theta H
minus Q1 star
theta L
I think over four.
Make sure I did that right.
Yeah, I think that should be good.
Okay.
And
we can immediately make one, you know,
I'm not going to solve this is a Yeah,
how you got that? I mean, this is just
algebra. I'm not going to bore you with
the details. I guess one nice
observation though to make sure we see
what's going on is what if we added
half of this equation to half of this
equation?
Uh if we did that,
what we would actually see
is it can be shown that in fact Q2 star
is going to equal
Q1 star of theta L
plus Q1 star of theta H
over two.
So, it turns out exactly consistent with
our original intuition.
Uh
the equilibrium quantity that Q2 star is
going to choose is exactly going to be
half of the quantity that the two firms
choose. And if we did it out, we'd
actually find that
the uh
it turns out the amount Q2 star will
actually be well,
if we did a complete information game
where the intercept was
the average between theta L and theta H
and we solved for the equilibrium of
that game,
we'd actually get the same number for Q2
star. Um but that's just a detail. Okay,
any questions on uh on how we how we
solve this. So, this is sort of a good
thing to know. This will come up
uh on some exams.
Okay, so now we're going to change
uh
course a little bit and start talking
about maybe a more substantive
application, really what I think
motivated us to set up Bayesian games
and that's the theory of auctions.
Now, we're going to start with auctions.
And we'll play a little auction game in
a second, but I want to start with just
some examples of auctions. Have any of
you
uh
been to an auction, played in an
auction, participated or know of
auctions? What are some auctions that uh
you've heard about or seen about? Yeah.
Treasury auctions are a great example.
Yeah, maybe one of the biggest ones.
Uh so, what's a treasury auction?
Uh
it's when the government basically
auctions off
government
like interest rate auctions. Great. Um
and this is sort of the way that kind of
the price and the interest rates that
you see for government debt are are set.
They're set endogenously by this
auction. Yeah.
Um so, that's a good example. That's the
government when the government wants to
borrow and raise money, they sell debt
and the price that's they sell it at is
through an auction. Yes. Fundraiser
auctions where you actually get my
notes.
Yeah. Um yeah, so fundraiser auctions.
Yeah, what kinds of items are they
auctioning off? Yeah.
Yeah.
It's good. Yeah, and I think this kind
of a game element to it and people kind
of show off about how much they bid and
uh
they feel good cuz they show off that
they're rich and charitable at the same
time.
Um so, that's that's I think why we see
auctions used there rather than just
prices and saying make a donation, you
get to get the warm glow and you take
the car. Uh any other
kind of common auctions?
Oh, yeah. Sorry, I didn't see you.
Google Ads. Uh great. Okay, so I think
uh when I've taught this course in the
past, no one's given that example and I
always have to bring it up. Uh Google
Ads is the biggest Google is the biggest
private auctioneer in the world.
Uh they make 250 billion a year on
auctions roughly
uh in revenue.
So, normally, yeah, every year I ask
this question, everyone always thinks
it's like Christie's or Sotheby's or one
of these people that's one of these
firms that's auctioning off paintings,
but indeed Google Ads is a much much uh
bigger market. So, I guess uh
great to see that answer. So, how does
Google Ads work? Or if you don't know,
that's okay, but just some thoughts. I
don't know
the point, but
I think it's a second price auction.
Okay. Where like everyone bids on an ad
space and then like the top bidder pays
the second highest bidder's price.
And then like it's ranked by like the
prominence of the ad. Yeah, yeah. So, so
so you're describing really a lot of
details which we're exactly going to go
into in a few classes. That's great. So,
have you Do you have experience Did you
work at Google or uh Yeah, I'm taking
1490 right now. Oh, okay. Great. Uh
um good. So, a little bit of overlap uh
with that course. So, I think, you know,
Google Ads has kind of two main
categories, right? One is when you
search on Google,
you see those sponsored advertisements
at the top. Those are keyword searches
where firms are bidding for the right to
be displayed. So, if you type in
vacation, a hotel or flight might want
to show their ad up there. The other way
they make money is through third-party
websites, right? So, if you go to the
New York Times and you see ads, uh those
ads are also, you know, managed through
Google and the New York Times if they
want to raise revenue and post ads on
their site, they'll use Google as a
third party and then Google will hold an
auction on their behalf where firms
might be bidding for the right to show
an ad to someone of a certain
demographic in a certain place who's uh
doing certain things. So, these ads are
very very targeted and that's been sort
of That's where Google makes all their
money. You might think, "Oh, they have a
great algorithm for search." But that
algorithm just enabled them to get
attention which they then monetize
through ads. Yeah. So, when you said
about the New York Times, does the New
York Times basically pay
Google to like take care of their ads?
Well, Google would pay them. Yeah, so
So, so if they they want to raise
revenue on their site, right?
Uh so, what would happen is I mean, they
could try to do it themselves, but
that's kind of hard. So, they would work
together with Google and then Google is
going to conduct these auctions. The
advertisers are going to pay Google and
then Google's going to give some cut to
the New York Times and then keep some
cut, right? So, the advertisers pay.
Why do they pay? Because they get to
show their ad and they hope they make
money off that.
Google is sort of the intermediary that
manages this and they're going to take a
cut. And then New York Times is able to
monetize some of the attention that they
generate because, you know, if the New
York Times does well and a lot of people
go to their site and uh look at their
ads, then uh they want to get some money
for this. Yeah. They're like not New
York Times ads. No, no. What I mean is
if you go to New York Times, you'll see
ads on the side, right? Which are not
have nothing to do with the New York
Times. I mean, the New York Times might
sometimes The New York Times also shows
some of their own ads, but um that's
just uh
uh and then the New York Times would
also be a player on other websites,
right? So, if you go to the Washington
Post, you might see a New York Times ad
next to it. That's because the New York
Times has bid through Google on an ad to
display on the on the Washington Post.
So, some firms are playing on both sides
of the market, right? They're both
buying ads through Google and also
advertising themselves on their site.
So, the New York Times is getting like
some of the money that's getting paid to
Google by the advertisers go to the New
York Times. So, like people take some of
that.
Yeah, I mean, you know, I don't know
exactly how the accounting, you know,
you could imagine it going different
ways, but at the end the money that's
paid by the advertiser, some is going to
go to Google and some is going to go to
New York Times. So,
Um
great. And then of course, if it's on
Google's own site, then there's no third
party and Google's just taking the money
directly, right? If it's a a sponsored
ad. Um
Okay. Uh I guess the classic one that we
often talk about, you know, paintings,
antiques.
And I think a basic question we should
ask, I mean, why
I've given some examples here. Most
things we buy in the world are not
auctioned off,
right? When you buy clothes at a store,
when you
go to a coffee shop, when you watch a
movie,
when you buy a drink, these things
generally there's a price. You get
dinner, there's a price that's posted
and you just pay it.
Whereas in these examples, we see
auctions used. Do you have any thoughts
about why we might see auctions in some
contexts
and
prices in in another? Uh maybe, yeah.
Uh price discovery. Okay, so say good
word. Yes. Say say more about it. Yeah.
It's a keyword. Uh for example, like in
a credit auction, like the government's
unsure how to value like a certain type
of bond. Um so, an auction like there's
kind of like a bunch of like literature
that suggests that it's like the most
efficient way to both like raise revenue
for the auctioneer, but then also to
efficiently allocate to all the
auctioneers. And it's like a price
revealing method.
Great. Great. So, let's say I have a
one-of-a-kind antique, right?
It might be pretty hard for me to know
how much people are willing to pay for
that. So, I could just post a price. I
say it's 10 million, but what I'd worry,
what if someone in the audience ended up
valuing that a lot? For some reason,
they really, really like this antique.
Now, I've wasted a lot of revenue. Um
so, we see auctions generally when firms
are uncertain about how much people are
willing to pay. With a coffee, that's a
bit different, right? Dunkin' Donuts
sells millions of coffees. They pretty
much know what the market price They
They pretty much know what people are
willing to pay for coffee. And also, it
would be
uh you know, if you had live auctions at
Dunkin' Donuts, I think it would be
pretty costly. We're talking about
pretty small amounts. Though, on the
other hand, Google Ads are very small
amounts. So, maybe there is a way. And
maybe eventually uh we will see auctions
for coffee as as everything gets
automated. Um
I guess one, you know, one final point
I'll make uh that I think is kind of a
new exciting area.
Google Ads used to be kind of the hot
new thing.
Google's losing a lot of money on this
now because everyone's just using LLMs.
Uh and I think there's a lot of interest
now in how LLMs are going to monetize
this through through auctions. So,
there's some talk now about Grok or uh
OpenAI might let firms bid for the right
to choose the next token that appears.
So, if you Google if you ask an LLM, you
know, where should I go on vacation, and
the LLM's response is, "Oh, a great
vacation destination is," you might have
firms bidding for the right to select
that next token. Uh and I think we're
not quite there well, we don't think
we're there yet. It's a little unclear.
Uh but we may be going going that
direction. I think that's an interesting
domain for future auction work.
Okay. So, we're going to start with some
models of very simple auctions.
Obviously, in these applications,
there's some complexity that that we're
not going to capture. Uh and we're going
to start with a simple uh sealed-bid
first-price auction.
So, we'll play this on MobLab.
What does a sealed bid mean? It means
you know, in the old days, you had an
envelope, and you gave it to the
auctioneer that said that that was the
amount of your bid. So,
submits
submits a bid.
It's sealed because that bid is not
observed. It's not like what you might
see in the movies where people are
calling out, you know, that's called an
open outcry auction. "Oh, I'll bid 100.
I'll bid 120." Something like that. It's
sealed. You're just submitting your bid
in an envelope.
First price,
well, what's going to happen is the
highest bidder is going to win,
and they're going to pay their bid.
So,
so, the highest bidder
wins the good,
and pays their bid.
The first-price nature is really
referring to the fact that the winner
pays their own bid. We'll also talk
about auctions where the winner might
pay the second-highest bid, something
like that. But for now, we're going to
just say the winner uh is going to pay
their bid. What is the private
information here? What are What are
these things that the information that
some players know that other players
don't in the context of an auction?
Yeah. How much they value the good.
Exactly right. So, here, each bidder
privately knows
what we might call their valuation,
right?
The valuation is going to be the most
they would be willing to pay for the
good. The way to think about the
valuation is if they were to win the
auction, win the good, and pay exactly
their valuation, they'd be just as well
off as if they didn't win the item at
all.
So, it's the amount that they could pay
that would make them exactly uh break
even.
Okay. So, these games, it's kind of
helps to have MobLab because we have to
generate randomly people's valuations.
So, let's uh log in to MobLab. I'm going
to try to set this up.
May have been a while, so I'll give you
a second.
Actually did pretty well. I'll put that
on here. Um
All right. So, here we see the groups.
Uh so, this is giving us uh a few
different piece of information here.
Uh let's understand what each of these
columns mean. So, we you were split into
six groups. You weren't a multiple of
three, so some of you we added robots to
the groups to to bid. I'm not exactly
sure. They probably follow the
equilibrium bidding strategy. I'm not
exactly sure how the robots play.
The first column is optimal surplus.
What that's referring to is, well, each
of the three people in the group have
some value for the good,
and that's referring to the the maximum
of those three values. Because the ideal
thing or the efficient thing would be to
give it to the person who values it
most, and it's saying how much value
would be created. So, uh here you see
these numbers are generally higher than
50 because the maximum of three of three
uniformly distributed numbers tends to
be pretty high.
Uh and we see the optimal surplus. Then
we see the surplus that was actually
achieved. So, we see in three of the
groups, in groups three through five,
the we got 100%.
What does that mean if we got 100%?
Precisely, what is
What does it mean exactly? Uh
Yeah, I'm fine. The surplus equals the
optimal surplus, something like
Uh yeah, so in in word, what's another
way of saying what happened in the
auction? Who won the auction? The person
who valued it.
The person Yeah, exactly what it means
is the person who valued the the item
the most is the one who won the auction
and took the item home. So, we see that
the allocation was quite efficient. Uh
in one case,
we see efficiency was 93%. That means
the item did not go to the person who
valued it most, but it happened to be
that someone else valued it almost as
much as the person who valued it most,
93%. And you know, so not too much of an
efficiency loss. In group five, we did a
little bit worse, 82%. And then the last
group, I think we just didn't finish uh
there. Uh and then we can see what the
revenue was for the auctioneer. So, that
So, another way of saying, in this case,
what is the revenue? Well, the winning
bidder pays their bid. So, the revenue
is exactly the winning bid.
Uh and you can see
uh
a few differences here. So, let's look
at group three.
In group three, the revenue was 94, and
the surplus was 94, and the optimal
surplus was 94. So, what happened in
group three?
Uh yeah.
The guy with the highest value bid the
value. Right. And won.
And that highest value was 94, right? Uh
exactly. So, how did How did that person
come I don't know. Who is the I don't
You know, you can out yourself, but uh
there's someone here. And how do you
feel about winning at at a price of 94?
I don't know who this person is. Do you
feel like you came away ahead or behind
or you won? How are you feeling? Yeah.
Since there was only one period, and I
wanted to win the auction, I just bid
all my
Oh, you had meaning your value or
literally all Like 94. 94. So, you bid
your valuation, right? Yeah, I guess I
all you had. I don't know how much you
have in the game. Um okay. So, so this
gets at some issues of preferences. If
your goal was to win the auction, maybe
that was a pretty good strategy. You did
win.
But remember the way that we defined
your valuation is that if you win the
item and pay your valuation, it's just
as good as not winning at all.
So, in a sense, you won, but in another
sense, you didn't do so well because you
got something that was worth $94. In the
extreme case, think of it as you paid
$94 to get $94, so it was kind of a it
was kind of a wash for you. But, you
know, you didn't lose, so that's good.
Uh I think
let's see how other people did. Who did
best? Uh we had the same issue in group
two. The winner bid uh exactly 59, and I
guess didn't didn't do so well. Uh it
was only
in in in group five, they bid 72 when
their value was 73. Does that person
want to share your thought? Okay. Yeah.
Well, I thought that
that's the
That's the maximum I could bid to at
least guarantee that I'll have a
positive payoff.
Yeah. I mean,
there's a chance I still would have won
if I had bid, say, 70, 71, or something.
And I would have a higher payoff, but
I think that there's no Like this
the probability that I win that's going
to go every time I bid lower. And I
still like even with my bid, even if I
do win, my payoff will be lower.
Okay. And indeed, you did come away with
a positive payoff. But I would argue
maybe you could have gotten an even more
positive payoff if you bid a little bit
lower. Uh let's see. What about the
person Someone bid 40 and won and valued
at 44. So, I think they were the kind of
overall winner. They They had the most
surplus of anyone. Yeah. Well, my
valuation was pretty low, so I thought I
would lose. Okay.
What's my optimal amount, but I thought
I would lose.
So, some people would argue, "Okay, I
think I'm going to lose. My value's low.
Why don't I bid more than my value to
have some chance of winning?" A lot of
people reason that way. Uh you didn't do
that. I think that would have been a bad
idea. Why Why did you not You thought
you're going to lose. Why didn't you bid
a lot more to try to win? Because then
my if I did win, my valuation would be
negative,
so I thought in this case, I'd rather
get a valuation of four or zero.
Exactly right. So, even if your
valuation is really low, it's true that
you're unlikely to win. But that might
tempt you to to overbid. That's not a
good idea because if you do win, you're
actually a loser because you uh your
valuation is smaller than the amount
that you bid. So, you bid $4 less than
your true valuation. In the end, you uh
you got Well, I don't know who else was
in your group, but you got There was
someone who had a value of 47. So,
actually, you uh
you got lucky, and you uh beat someone
who actually had a valuation higher than
you. Uh and you came away with a
surplus. So, my overall, I would say
people are maybe not ready to
to bid for Google or bid bid for New
York Times. I think there was some some
some poor bidding I don't know. Okay,
bidding here. I think people generally
bid a bit too high. So, if you see
uh they've actually computed the Nash
equilibrium uh line, which is the dotted
green line, and you can see everyone's
actually bid I think every single person
bid higher than than would be optimal to
to bid.
Um and I think this is a very common
finding when you do things in the lab.
And I think it gets to Do we have the
right model of preferences, right? I
think there's a certain uh excitement
people get for winning, and they want to
win even if it means they end up paying
paying a little bit too much. So, people
tend to overbid in first price auctions
and that might actually be a reason why
we see a lot of first price auctions in
practice even though the theory would
tell us that second price auctions have
some more desirable properties that
we'll we'll talk about. Um
let's maybe let's do it one more time
but now let's make it a second price
auction and uh
see what happens.
How do I change it?
I'm not going
Okay.
Now, I just have to add it again. That's
silly.
So, now let's make it a second price
auction.
So, what does a second price auction
mean?
Well, the highest bidder is still going
to win the item but now they're going to
pay the second highest bid rather than
their own bid.
Okay.
So, this should should change
how you play.
Uh
So,
curious how things went. So, here we
let's look at group one. Here that we
actually went groups of six. So, the
optimal surpluses tended to be very high
because we're looking at the maximum of
six different uh random variables. It
was efficiently allocated every single
time
and it looks like the revenue
uh
was
I guess it's a bit hard to know from the
data we're seeing here uh but looks
pretty good. It actually looks like
people are bidding
basically
their valuations. This is basically a
straight line. So, people are actually
very very consistent. Uh do people want
to share how they how they thought about
this?
I'm actually a bit surprised by this.
This is not how it usually goes. Uh
yeah, in the back. I think in my notes
there was like an analysis of second
price auctions and it says like it's
most optimal to own
Okay, that's a good answer. Yeah, that's
exactly right. Uh so, maybe people read
the notes. I'm surprised so many people
read the notes. Uh I thought uh so, I
think I've done this in past years and
normally when I tell people they bid too
high in the first price auction, we then
go to this and they bid really low.
Um
but indeed, if it's a second price
auction, it's actually optimal to bid
your true valuation and not to bid less
than your true valuation. What's
different here? I said before if you bid
your valuation, then you can never win
any money. So, what's different in the
second price auction? So, yeah. I bid my
valuation as
as someone said earlier sort of like my
highest
um
I have a pretty high chance to win but
then I've actually given a price that's
below that because you're getting the
second highest bidder. So, you know,
you're getting
a positive value back as well. Exactly
right. So, in the first price auction,
if I bid my valuation, then if I win the
auction, I'm actually going to pay my
bid. So, I'm going to pay my valuation
and therefore I don't come out ahead.
But in the second price auction, if I
bid my valuation, well, I'm not actually
going to have to pay my valuation if I
win. I don't know what I'll pay but I'll
pay the second highest bid which will
always be strictly lower than my
valuation and we'll go over the argument
I think in next class about exactly why
bidding your own value is is exactly
optimal in a second price auction. And
uh this is why one nice thing about
second price auctions is you don't
actually have to think too much about
how much other people value the good. In
the first price auction, you really have
to think hard about how much the other
people are going to bid and try to
respond strategically to that. Okay, so
let's close this down and uh let's
actually analyze uh the simplest
possible example of a first price sealed
bid auction and try to solve for the
equilibrium of this auction.
So, auction solving for auction
equilibrium can get a bit a bit messy.
So, let's start with the simplest
possible example which is a first price
sealed bid auction
with two bidders.
I equals one and two
and let's assume that each bidder's
valuation for the good is uniformly
drawn from between zero and one. Okay?
So, be before in the example in the the
MobLab example, I think it was zero to
100. We're just going to change units
now. So,
so bidder I's valuation
we'll call that VI. So, bidder I's
valuation VI
uh this is going to be in 01
and it's uniformly distributed
and independent.
Uniform
uh
just means that
the probability that my value is in any
subinterval of 01 is just the length of
that interval.
So,
uh the probability that my value is
between zero and 0.2 is just 0.2. So,
it's pretty easy to calculate these
uh with
these probabilities with uniform
distributions. Another way of saying
that if you're if you've taken some
probability is the PDF the probability
density function is just one.
Independent what I mean by that is that
bidder one's valuation is independent
statistically of bidder two's valuation.
So, what that means is if I know my own
valuation V1
I still believe that my opponent's
valuation is uniformly distributed. My
valuation provides no information about
the valuation of the other bidders,
right? At the extreme other case would
be we all valued exactly the same amount
but that's not what we're studying here.
Okay?
And you know, each bidder
can submit a bid
we'll call it bid
let's say BI which is just a
non-negative number
simultaneously. So, here are the
bidders. They each privately draw their
valuations. Each bidder knows her own
valuation but not the other player's
valuation and then submits the bid
BI to the auctioneer.
And then what happens? Well,
the higher bid
the higher bidder, that is the bidder
who bids more
wins good wins the item
and pays bid.
So, I think the first step
to analyzing this auction is to try to
understand what each player's payoff is
in the auction. What is their utility as
a function of their valuation and how
much they bid?
So, let's go over here.
So, formally
this auction induces a Bayesian game
where each bidder is the action they can
choose is how much to bid and their
payoffs are going to be what we write
down here. So, let's look at player one.
We could work reason about player I but
I think that just makes it a little more
abstract. So, let's look at U1
player one's utility as a function of
well, what are the things that can
affect player one's utility?
How much they bid?
How much the other player bids and also
how much they value the good.
Right?
So, we're going to write U1 of B1
B2
V1.
So, these are the bids of both players.
Why does the other player's bid affect
my payoff? So, I'm player one. Why do I
care about the other player's bid? Yeah.
Because if you bid higher than the other
player, then you're kind of
then you have actually a bigger value
than finding the payoff. Otherwise, if
the other player bids higher than your
value, then
your utility
Right. So,
the other bidder's bid affects me
because it affects whether I win.
It doesn't affect how much I pay if I
win. I always pay my own bid. But it
affects whether I win. So, that's
relevant to my utility.
Also, of course, my valuation V1 is also
relevant.
This is bidder one's valuation.
It turns out bidder two's valuation
doesn't enter here because all I care
about is what we bid and how much I
value the good. Of course, in the game,
the other player's valuation might
affect how much they choose to bid under
their equilibrium strategy but in terms
of just the payoffs, we just want to
write payoffs as a function of actions
and uh types or state. So, let's try to
fill this in.
So, if we want to be really formal, then
V1 would sort of be playing the role of
of your type or of the state of nature
uh going back to our formalism of about
Bayesian games. So, now I want to write
down this payoff function. I think it's
helpful to separate into three cases.
And in a sense, I should say that what
we're going to fill in here
is basically
what defines
the first price auction, right? Um the
rules of the first price auction are
going to determine what the payoffs are
here. If we had a different auction
format, then our payoffs as a function
of the bids would be different because
those bids would be aggregated in a
different way.
So, let's say B1 is less than B2. I
think this is the easiest case. What is
player one's utility going to be in this
case?
Zero, right? If their bid's lower, they
lose.
If they lose, they win nothing, they pay
nothing, their utility is zero. Let's
now look at
this case.
What's their utility going to be here?
Uh yeah. V1 minus B2.
Exactly.
So, what happens here? I'm bidder one. I
bid higher than my opponent. That means
I'm the highest bidder, so I win.
Because I win the good, I get my
valuation V1, but I have to pay my bid.
And my bid was B1. So, V and B sound
kind of similar, but my total payoff is
V1 minus B1.
What about uh
this case here? Well, we have to make a
choice about how we break ties.
Normally, when things are continuous,
this isn't so important. Uh normally,
what we imagine is that both people bid
the same amount, we flip a coin to see
who wins.
So, we flip a coin.
Uh
if it's heads, player one wins and pays
their bid. If it's tails, player two
wins and pays their bid. So, what is
player one's expected payoff going to be
in this case?
Exactly, right? So,
there's a half chance they win the coin
flip. If they lose the coin flip, they
get zero. If they win the coin flip,
they get this payoff.
So, we just get V1.
minus B1. Okay.
Exactly. Exactly, right.
Let's just as uh as an exercise just to
make sure we understand things,
we're going to solve the first-price
auction, but let's just imagine if it
was a second-price auction, let's see
how these payoffs would change, okay?
So, just as a to make sure we're on the
same page.
If it were second price, well,
the number of bidders is the same, the
valuations are the same, they're still
bidding as before, except instead, the
higher bidder wins the item and pays the
second highest bid.
Then we're going to have a different
expression for this utility.
Um
what would it be? So, let's just kind of
go through on the other side.
Uh I think this is still the easy case.
What if this is second-price auction?
Then, what what's the payoff here for
bidder one?
Exactly. Yeah, so so otherwise uh
everything is exactly the same, right?
Good. So, it's still zero here because
if I bid less than the other player, I
lose.
If we let's go down here. If I bid more
than the other player, I win, but now I
pay the second highest bid, not the
highest bid.
If I'm bidder one and I bid more than
the other player, then their bid is the
second highest bid. So, I'm going to get
V1 minus
B2.
And indeed uh in the middle, we're going
to flip a coin again, so there's a half
chance I win, in which case I get V1
minus Well, here it actually notice, in
this case, B1 equals B2, so I could
write B1 or B2, it won't matter, but
I'll write B2 cuz I think it's uh more
intuitive. So, exactly, right.
Okay, so that uh you'll see how
you know, this is going to fundamentally
change the incentives of the bidder.
Uh a key difference, a special property
of the second-price auction, notice, is
that your bid B1 affects whether you
win,
but not your payoff if you do win.
In a first-price auction, my bid B1
affects whether I win,
but also what my utility is if I do win.
And these are these two counteracting
forces. Um
So now, let's see if we can
solve for an equilibrium.
So, let's go through our steps, right?
The first step is to figure out what
kind of objects the the strategies are,
right? We first have to figure out what
the strategies are. So, let's say
solving
for
Bayes-Nash equilibrium.
What is a strategy
for let's say we have firm one
and firm two.
So, as before, a strategy has to specify
what action you're going to take as a
function of your private information, as
a function of what you know, because you
can only condition your action on things
you know.
So, what can firm one condition their
bid on?
Their own valuation, right? And indeed,
that's what a strategy is going to be.
It's going to have to specify my action,
that is, how much I bid, as a function
of my valuation. And this is where
understanding function notation is
really important, we have to be careful
about this, so it's going to be a
function B1
from
0 1
to
maybe I'll write R plus to denote the uh
non-negative real numbers, right?
So, what does this say?
My strategy is a function B1
that takes in any possible valuation I
could have for the good. We said the
valuations live in 0 1.
And it assigns to each of those
valuations an amount that I bid.
So,
what's tricky here is that before, in
our Cournot example,
firm one only had two types.
So, we had to specify two numbers, how
much they produced in the high state and
how much they produced in the low state.
Now, we have a continuum.
So, one way of thinking about a function
is it's like a continuous vector. We're
having to specify infinitely many, in
fact, continuously many numbers. And
that's why solving for auction
equilibrium is going to be quite hard,
because we need to understand not just
how each bidder actually bids, but how
they would have bid if their valuation
were different.
And we're going to have the same thing
FOR
SO, WE'VE GOT TO SOLVE FOR A LOT OF
THINGS HERE.
Um
we could write out the full equilibrium
condition,
but
I think the trick with a lot of these
auction equilibria, at least in this
case, is we're going to make a guess.
We're going to use guess and check.
So, what's our strategy?
I shouldn't say strategy, that would
cause confusion. Uh
okay, we want to guess and check. What's
our approach?
So, we're going to look for an
equilibrium of a very specific form.
So, we're going to guess
a
symmetric equilibrium.
I think it's pretty intuitive that the
equilibrium will be symmetric here
because the distributions of the
valuations are symmetric.
Now, remember, symmetric doesn't mean
the two players will always bid the same
amount, because the two players may have
different valuations for the good. What
symmetric means is the two players use
the same strategy, which means if player
two had a valuation of 0.7, she would
bid the same amount as player one would
bid if she had a valuation of 0.7.
So, in a symmetric equilibrium,
B1 of V, I'll just use V to denote uh
generic value,
equals B2 of V
for all V.
So, this says if bidder one's valuation
is V,
the amount that she bids is the same
that bidder two bids if her valuation is
V.
Maybe I'll put stars here to show that
this is a equilibrium. But we want to
guess a bit more about the structure
of these bidding functions, because now
we have to solve for infinitely many
numbers. That's a bit hard. So, we want
to guess that the bidding function takes
kind of a nice form.
And it turns out that the trick here is
to guess what's called a a linear
bidding function,
where everyone just bids their value
times a fraction, times a constant.
So, let's call it alpha
V.
So, we're guessing a symmetric
equilibrium that takes this special
form.
And we're going to try to solve
for alpha.
Any guesses about the value that alpha
might have? What
you know, is it going to be bigger than
one, less than one, positive, negative?
Any thoughts about this thing, alpha?
Yeah. Something positive less than one.
Positive less than one is a good guess,
right? Because
we know, and we saw from sort of the
example, that I want to what's called
shade my bid. I want to bid less than my
true valuation. So, certainly alpha
should be less than one. Uh you can't
bid negative amounts, and we'd like your
bid to be We think it should be
increasing in your value. So, it makes
sense for alpha to be non-negative, or
it's really going to be strictly
positive. So, in general, the idea is
you're going to get some value V,
and instead of bidding your true value,
you're going to bid some fraction of
that value. And our goal is to is to
solve for that alpha.
So, step one is our guess.
And step two is we're going to check
that this is actually an equilibrium.
Now, the checking is the hardest is the
tricky part, and I want to make a
is a really important point here.
It's not enough to say,
"Suppose my opponent is using a linear
bidding strategy alpha V,
then the best linear bidding strategy
for me is also alpha V." That's not
enough, because I could deviate to a
non-linear strategy. So, to understand,
we're looking for an equilibrium where
both firms use linear strategies, but
the firms could deviate to non-linear
strategies as well. We're not
restricting them to using linear
strategies.
So, the way we check this
is we want to say,
so check
if
B2 of V
equals alpha V.
So, if bidder two is following this
strategy,
then the best bidding strategy for firm
one, or for bidder one, is also alpha V.
So, we're going to suppose that my
opponent is using this strategy,
and then compute what's the best way for
bidder one to bid, and check if that
happens to be the same strategy.
If it doesn't work out, then that means
our original guess was wrong, and there
isn't equilibrium of this form. If it
does work out, then we'll be able to
solve for for alpha.
So, I guess that's a a key step of guess
and check.
The output of guess and check will
either be
I made a good guess, here's the
equilibrium, or will be my guess was
wrong. I guessed an equilibrium of a
particular form that didn't exist, and
then let me try again.
Of course in class we're
going to make good guesses, but on your
homework you might make a guess that it
turns out to be wrong.
Okay, let's let's move over here.
So,
following our guess and check strategy,
we're going to suppose
B2 of V
equals alpha V for some alpha that we're
going to try to solve for later. So, for
an arbitrary alpha.
Say for some
fixed
alpha
that's maybe between 0 and 1.
And now we want to consider
bidder one
with valuation V1.
And we want to say put yourselves in the
shoes of bidder one.
Suppose your valuation for the item is
V1.
Suppose you believe that the other
bidder is following this bidding
strategy, what is the optimal bid for
you as bidder one?
So, what are they trying to do?
They want to their goal is to maximize
over B1
their expected payoff.
Well, let's go over and look at our
formula
and try to compute our expected payoff.
Now, the tricky thing is we can't just
plug in a single number for firm two's
bid, bidder two's bid, because bidder
two's bid depends on bidder two's
valuation, and we don't know what that
is.
So, what we're going to have to do is
take expectations
over
what the value of bidder two is.
So, we're going to maximize what? We're
going to take expectations
of U1
B1
B2 of V2
V1. I think this is the key step. So,
let's understand what's going on here.
What I'm taking expectations over is V2.
This is the random thing.
Because as player from my perspective as
player one, I don't know what the
valuation of bidder two is.
So, this is the thing I don't know
about.
V1 is not random. V1 is my valuation as
bidder one, and I know what that is. So,
this is fixed.
B2 of V2 is the amount that bidder two
bids when their valuation is V2.
And under our supposition, we know that
this is going to be alpha
V2.
But even though we know what bidder two
bids as a function of their valuation,
we don't know what they actually bid
because we don't know what their
valuation is. So, it's alpha V2, but we
don't know what V2 is.
And then B1 is a number.
This is my bid.
So, just to be clear, what's inside the
expectation is what is my payoff going
to be if it turns out that the valuation
of bidder two is V2.
And that's what we get in here, and then
I'm taking expectations over that. Okay?
So, now let's try to simplify this.
Well,
in a lot of cases
this is just zero.
Right? This is only going to be non-zero
when my bid is bigger than my opponent's
bid.
And when my bid is bigger than my
opponent's bid, this is exactly what I
get.
So, it turns out we can write this as
as this.
Let's understand what's going on here.
To compute my expected payoff, we just
have to say well, there's two
possibilities.
Either I win or I lose.
If I lose the auction, I pay nothing and
I get nothing, so my payoff is zero. So,
you don't even have to worry about that.
You can think of us adding
plus zero times the probability that my
bid is lower than the other if you want,
but that doesn't change things.
V1 minus B1 is what I get if I win, but
I have to multiply that by the
probability that I do win.
Uh one second, yeah. What is the
probability that I do win?
Well, I'm going to win if my bid B1 is
higher than my opponent's bid alpha V2.
And we really have to understand
crucially here in this probability, the
random thing is V2.
B1 is not random. B1 is a number, I know
what B1 is. What's random is V2, and
that's what we're taking probabilities
over. Yes. Are we just not considering
the tie case because we have a
continuous distribution so the
probability that Exactly right. So, you
could add a third, really we could think
of it as three numbers, right? It's this
times this probability,
maybe maybe we'll write it out to make
it clearer, plus zero times the
probability that B1 is less than alpha
V2
plus V1 minus B1
plus 1/2
probability that B1
equals alpha V2. This is the full
expression, but this disappears because
we have a zero.
And this disappears because the
probability that B1 is exactly alpha V2
is zero. Why? It's always tricky to say
the probability that B1 is something.
Remember, B1 is just a number. So, what
I really mean is the probability that
alpha V2 is equal to this fixed number
B1. That's also zero.
So, that cancels, and I just get this
expression.
Now, we see the basic trade-off that we
always face in auction theory.
If I increase B1
then when I win the item, I pay more,
and therefore I win less when I win.
But, I win more often.
If I reduce my bid,
then I then winning is even better
because I pay less when I win, but
winning happens less often because I'm
less likely to win. And the optimal bid
is exactly going to trade off those two
forces. Right? Notice I'm not putting
weight on just whether I win or not.
It's how well I do when I win. If my
goal was just to win, well,
or just to win and make positive
profits, then I would just bid exactly
or just below my valuation, but I care
about how much I win when I do win. So,
let's go to a new board and finish this
off.
Well, let's write this in a different
way. We have V1 minus B1 times the
probability, well, the random thing is
V2. So, let's focus on V2. This is V2
less than
B1
over alpha.
Uh
but
what is this going to equal for a
uniform distribution?
Yeah. B1 over alpha. Just B1 over alpha.
We we have to be a little careful that
uh B1
uh if B1 over alpha is if B1 is bigger
than alpha, then it could be one, but um
it turns out we usually aren't that
careful about that. So, let's just say
if
B1
less than or equal to alpha, it turns
out you're never going to want to bid
more than
uh
alpha because if you bid more than
alpha, you're already going to win
anyway, so you're just increasing the
amount that you pay. Right? Let's
understand. If my opponent's strategy is
alpha times V2, the highest they could
possibly bid is alpha. So, it'd be crazy
for me to bid more than alpha cuz I'm
already guaranteed to win by bidding
alpha. So, it's a safe assumption that
B1 is less than alpha, and in that case
then we indeed get B1 over alpha.
So, now if we simplify, we get V1 minus
B1
times B1
over alpha.
And if we maximize this
we're actually going to get B1 star
equals
V1 over two.
Cuz the alpha doesn't affect you. You
could do the first order condition, but
it's our classic trick.
B1 times V1 minus B1 is maximized by B1
equals V1 over two.
Wait a second.
Was our guess wrong? We guessed that
player two was using a bidding strategy
of alpha V
and our best response for bidder two is
to always bid V1 over two.
So, it was our guess right?
How can we make sure that this agrees
with our guess? How do we have a
symmetric equilibrium?
Alpha equals a half, right?
So, we conclude
that alpha equals a half.
And let's just go through the reasoning,
right? If alpha equals a half, then both
bidders are using the bidding strategy
where they bid exactly half their value.
Given that the other bidder is is
bidding half their value, well, that's a
special case of alpha times their value.
So, my best response is half my value,
and that shows that I'm bidding
optimally given the way my opponent is
bidding. So, the key property is that
when we solve for the maximizer, we got
something within the linear family. We
got a new linear function with
coefficient 1/2, and then we just
matched our coefficients. Uh and we set
alpha equal to 1/2.
So, we'll continue this uh
on Thursday.
Great.